[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue à sainte marie vous
êtes chez be format suivez-moi
[Musique]
moi c'est dimitri en berry donc j'ai 38
ans donc je suis gérant de la société
demi format qui a été créée au 5 août
2019 il faisant de la formation alors
moi je suis issu de la restauration la
base c'était manager très tôt à 19 ans
j'ai évolué très vite 24 ans j'étais
directeur adjoint d'un restaurant puis
par la suite j'ai quitté j'ai fait un
master en management puis un billet
stratégie d'entreprise je les fais en
même temps la création de mon entreprise
et j'étais accompagné par réussite et un
soutien financier aussi avec l'adil avec
un prêt à 5000 euros est vraiment m'a
aidé à créer cette entreprise chaque
entité
mon but c'était de créer quelque chose
d'innovant tu es différent mon idée
c'était vraiment de faire la formation
certifiante donc on a créé des formats
et que des activités une activité de
formation professionnelle plutôt
certifiantes et l'a dernièrement on a
créé une innovation à la réunion de
faire de la formation en apprentissage à
distance et à côté on fait aussi du
conseil on accompagne les entreprises
dans du digital et de la création
d'entreprise on a 90 % de stagiaires qui
sont basés en métropole on fait aussi de
la formation en présentiel donc on
accompagne des entreprises on a formé
plus de 200 managers cette année dans un
grand groupe alors dans le domaine du
marketing digital propose de la
formation dans la création de sites
internet les réseaux sociaux la vidéo et
toutes ces formations dont toute cette
petite formation sont certifiantes sont
reconnus par l'état et de l'autre côté
la formation en alternance en
apprentissage on est en partenariat avec
un grand groupe study study qui est le
numéro un actuellement de la formation à
distance aujourd'hui à la réunion on
peut dire on propose de 56 formation
diplômante du bac à bac +5 en alternance
et à tout moment c'est que les gens
n'ont pas de date de rentrée la rentrée
chez nous c'est tout le temps et du coup
à la clé un emploi à tourner
alors bis format est une entreprise
performante parce qu'il forma à créer de
l'emploi on a embauché quatre personnes
en cdi des personnes en cdd des
apprentis donc aujourd'hui on est à huit
personnes et on a une perspective
d'embauché 2022 à 3 4 personnes de plus
et on a un chiffre d'affaires
aujourd'hui qui a évolué extrêmement
vite première année un peu près 60 mille
euros et la troisième année on est à un
million cent mille euros la performance
elle est là mais il ya aussi une
performance qualité on a été certifié
très vite qu hadopi on est certifié sur
les quatre actions actions de formation
action formation par apprentissage vae
et bilan de compétences mais quasi les
seuls à la réunion à voir ces quatre
niveaux de certification
ça montre aussi une certaine qualité qui
sont proposés le somme due forme à la
compétence acquiert par l'apprentissage
par l'expérience par l'échec aussi donc
n'arrêtait jamais d'apprendre c'est là
qu'elle barrios
et